in their day-to-day routine MEP is a
point debate supervised and with member
states decide on key European issues
they rarely investigate but the tools
are there the committee of inquiry and
the temporary or special committee these
are limited to examinations of alleged
breaches or poor application of
community law they're decided by plenary
vote at the request of a quarter of all
751 mep s before that the move must have
been approved by the conference of
presidents of the seven main political
groups once mandated the committee can
question witnesses and is entitled to
documents pertinent to the case
generally the special or temporary
committee has more members more staff
but fewer powers it too has to have the
agreement of the conference of
presidents usually it's 12 months in
duration at the end it can recommend
legislation which the Commission as the
initiator of EU legislation can decide
to follow up on or not there have been
only three committees of inquiry into
the collapse of the equitable life
assurance society the BSE or mad cow
crisis and the communities transit
regime relating to non-eu Goods
transiting the EU in the past special
committees have looked at human genetics
safety at sea climate change the
financial crisis the echelon electronic
eavesdropping system the use by the CIA
of European countries to snatch
terrorism suspects and the tax rulings
of some Member States favorable to some
multinational corporations on this last
one they decided to set up a special
committee after the tax ruling scandal
was revealed in Luxembourg the
Netherlands Belgium and Ireland there's
one thing however which is important to
point out at the outset these are not
criminal investigations it's about
fact-finding about getting answers to
who where Hulk when
and anywhere else the first task of the
special committee is to define its
working practices and timetable to
select the chair vice chairs reporters
and shadow reporters this one will be
traveling a lot visiting member states
to build up a comprehensive picture a
strong team that is now but you'll it
will turn a dream team if it generates a
few nightmares to solve the brief says
mr. Lamas or chair of the special
committee who's a former french minister
is boiled down to this ramon de he do
sev wah the fifth ave were in the policy
what does that mean in more detail in
terms of scope and function zone
neurosis is fully high enough argument
vacant team and by shifting violence in
the mvd cadichon flag and under starts
and Reggie on chefs under EU Commission
Stalin it's not a persecution its effect
finding strong mission it doesn't have
as many powers as a pure inquiry
committee but I think as a first move
this will be strong enough the [ __ ]
hide hot jackets actor so you so do you
say I'll off Merc son kite a heightened
Indian media no dummy politician talk
instead everybody Parliament not soon
I'll meet leached out in one respect
this special committee doesn't feel
underpowered power is after all
influence and a great deal of that is
generated by the media and by social
platforms New Zealand movie a seat until
net the many arts were to pursue your
way deserve for my co adoni Vicki's rape
wet at Des Moines a priest Lafitte
Parliament's right of inquiry is an
important tool in the exercise of its
democratic oversight it isn't allowed
and doesn't pretend to supersede
national parliaments but it does want to
get at the truth through focused inquiry
and to exert influence where it can with
a weight of public opinion behind it
you